Hollywood legend Steven Spielberg is
behind a powerful new documentary series
set to air on the Discovery Channel why
we hate is a six-part series that begins
this Sunday
it takes a close look at hatred and
emotion that's been part of the human
experience throughout history and how we
can fight it mark Strassmann spoke with
the spiel with Spielberg for an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning
hate in 2019 comes at us from anywhere
in politics sports road rage
the Internet can often feel like a giant
hate group the seeds of our psychology
is really built to look for threats why
we hate Discovery Channel's new global
series argues hate is human it's
hardwired into our DNA this has been a
subject that has been very close to me
personally and a subject that seems to
be even more relevant today compared to
even 10 years ago is this a Legacy
Project well I don't think of it as a
Legacy Project I think of it as sort of
a mandatory project as hate become the
new normal
no I think hate is the constant abnormal
Steven Spielberg's co-executive producer
is Alex Gibney he had me at hate as they
say the oscar-winning documentarian one
of the first things we thought about was
finding hate detectives people who are
not presenters who are not lecturers but
people who would explore those hate
detectives begin with a team of
cognitive and evolutionary scientists
who did getting to hates origins
chimpanzees and bonobos are actually
more closely related to us genetically
than they are to gorillas that then led
me to wonder are they capable of hate or
is it at how we can hate one another
really special about
the series searches for those answers
and brings haida live with personal
stories the haters hatred was is
building up in the period and I found my
safe place and those targeted by hate
you could write a book on every word
that I've been called did you identify
with him from experiences in your own
life well I'd certainly identified with
what it feels like to be bullied which I
was as a elementary and high school
student for a while Sam Pollard and
Geeta Gunn deburr co-directed the series
I was told that I was different I've
been told to go back to where I came
from
people around the world can watch this
series and see some of themselves and
maybe rethink their own attitudes take
sports why we hate explores how rabid
rooting for your team can spark
tribalism hatred on a group scale the
same us-versus-them mindset behind much
of the world's misery I saw me okay son
of Boston loved the Red Sox I've said
since I was a kid I hate the Yankees and
frankly when I watched that and maybe
think I should probably tone that detox
detox right did you say to yourself you
know what if I'm being honest with
myself I'm kind of guilty of that too
well yeah I mean I'm certainly I'm
certainly guilty about snap judgment I'm
guilty about impulsive behavior some of
that Celinda interesting movies has an
application in my life which is I don't
want to divest myself up people are
complicated they can also grow Spielberg
and Gibney hope will watch the series as
critical thinkers of the world and of
ourselves the human brain is a
changeable system and we can unlearn
hate just as quickly as we can acquire
it
our hope is our ability as human beings
to access the better angels of our
nature in many of life's moments a deep
breath a detox to use Alex Gibney's word
would be a healthy start for CBS this
morning
mark Strassmann Los Angeles may we never
get to the place where hate is the new
normal yeah I think we can all watch you
watch this documentary and learn
something from it yeah okay so angry so
easily so quickly these days